Будівлю грузинського уряду обливають червоною фарбою, яка символізує кров.
Це не просто перфоманс чи вандалізм заради вандалізму.
Це закид, що саме уряд несе відповідальність за побиття понад півсотні журналістів і смерть телеоператора Лексо Лашкарави.
5 липня він знімав сутички, пов'язані з акцією протесту проти проведення у Грузії маршу на підтримку ЛГБТК-спільноти.
Представники сексменшин постійно зазнають погроз та утисків у Грузії, де панують патріархальні устої,
а Церква й влада закликають не проводити марші гідності.
Під час зйомок невідомі радикали напали на телеоператора і жорстоко побили його.
Лашкараву госпіталізували з переломами кісток обличчя і сильною гематомою на місці лівого ока.
Кілька днів тому він виписався з лікарні і продовжував лікування вдома.
Але 11 липня чоловіка знайшли мертвим у себе вдома.
Точна причина смерті наразі невідома. Попередньо порушено справу за статтею про доведення до самогубства.
Пізніше справу можуть перекваліфікувати. Після звістки про смерть Лашкарави на вулиці Тбілісі вийшли тисячі людей на акції протесту.
Ми вважаємо уряд безпосередньо відповідальним за те, що не було забезпечено безпеку журналістів,
і тому ми вважаємо, що відставка прем'єр-міністра та уряду є єдиною відповіддю,
яка буде задовільною для грузинського суспільства за таких обставин.
Окрім Лашкарави, під час сутичок постраждали понад 50 журналістів.
Опозиція вважає, що насильство під час протестів проти маршу ЛГБТК-спільноти санкціонував уряд.
Це дуже чіткий меседж. Уряд, який організував за допомогою радикальних угруповань погроми,
спеціально спрямовані проти журналістів (і вже є кілька людей, які постраждали, а нині й один загиблий), має піти у відставку.
Грузинська поліція вже затримала двох осіб у справі про напад на телеоператора Лексо Лашкараву і журналістку Міранду Багатурія.
За словами ж самої журналістки, нападників було набагато більше - до 20 осіб.
Представники ЗМІ теж вийшли на вулицю, щоб підтримати постраждалих колег.
Ми тут разом, щоб усі побачили, що ЗМІ - єдині, щоб показати солідарність.
Людям це може не подобатися і вони можуть відчувати дискомфорт, але справедливість буде панувати в цій країні.
І так: ми змусимо всіх дотримуватися верховенства права, бо якщо ви просто тримаєте камеру і мікрофон, за це вас не можуть покарати і вбити.
Я прийшов сюди зі своєю дитиною, бо стояв тут і за неї, і за всіх, і за вбитого Лексо.
За ним сумуватиме не лише його родина і колеги по телебаченню, а й усі ми.
Грузинські ЗМІ мають залишатися нині сильними, і тому кожен у цій будівлі повинен розуміти, що преса не може мовчати.
І Лексо має бути останньою жертвою у найближчому майбутньому та в історії.
Акції протесту в Грузії не вщухають. Опозиція навіть штурмувала будівлю парламенту.
За даними міжнародної правозахисної організації "Репортери без кордонів", індекс свободи преси у Грузії за минулий рік трохи погіршився,
але позиція країни загалом не змінилася.
Грузія посідає 60 місце зі 180 держав і це найкращий результат з усіх пострадянських республік, окрім країн Балтії.
Нинішні події, за оцінками експертів, серйозно вплинуть на репутацію Грузії.
Окрім опозиції, в злочинній пасивності владу обвинувачують і міжнародні організації.
Тим часом у МВС Грузії запевняють, що поліція була максимально мобілізована і робила все, що в їхніх силах.
При цьому переслідування журналістів відбувалось одночасно у різних місцях і було безпрецедентним.
Це визнав і міністр внутрішніх справ Вахтанг Гомелаурі.
За словами правозахисників, влада у Грузії, як правило, не втручається у ті випадки, коли мова йде про радикальні угруповання,
у яких нібито вже виробився синдром безкарності за свої дії.